Ngoài Hà Mí Lâm, người dưới sống tạm dưới mỗi.
Chuy nhắn tự tài đường sắp nhà trang cho biết mưa lớn kéo dài trên địa bàn tình khánh hoa đã làm nhiều đoạn tuyên qua khu dân ná ba.
Cám thịt đông, cám dành, đi ngập và sật lời của bộ.
Một ngành đường sắp tạm dưới trẻ tạo từ 15-8 mưu phút để bảo đam ăn toàn.
Vì những tài kilomét 18,5 xong vi chính cộng 1,2 mí mốt, lúc ngập đường dây khoảng khu vệ 2,5 mưu.
Tài kilomét 18,5 xong vi bẩy cộng nằm nơi, đất đã chẳng dú lúc hệ dài.
Zó anh vừa sự cố, các tàu S A xó, S A, M A, và S A, M A mốt phải chư tạm các la cám thịt đông, cà dông và nhá trang.
Hành khách được bộ chiến nơi nghỉ và cũng cấp như yếu phẩm trong thời gian trở thông tuyến.
Chúng khi đó, đại khi tự thủy văn khánh hoa kánh báo, vi cơ cao sẻ ra lũ quát và sật lời đất sò lượng ngừa lưới kéo dài, độ âm đất của tảm y ra trang.
Dự báo trong sấu dơ tối, khu vực tiếp tục có mưa bộ miếp để tảm y mấy mấy mấy mấy mấy mấy mấy thêm ở dưới gió mất ăn toàn.